I think it's my job to reach out to my
staff to recognize them for all the hard
work they're doing and to do well just
random acts of kindness to make sure
that everybody's feeling good with that
in mind I want to do something a little
special right now with the very
important person in my life and on my
staff my assistants um obsession
sonar you there yeah I'm here you know
you mean the world to me and with that
in mind I had something delivered to
your house it's perfectly safe I had it
wiped down and followed all the
protocols can you just go get it and
bring it to the camera yeah okay that
door needs oil Sona you got it yeah I
open it well hold on before you open it
I just want to say that it felt high
time to recognize someone who's doing a
killer job on the show so open it up and
show everybody what it is okay
what's it say this is employee of the
month
Conan O'Brien wait a minute I won
I got employee of the month that's
fantastic
why are you acting so surprised what did
you think was gonna be in the box I'm a
busy guy and I've been ordering myself a
lot of awards lately and I forgot which
one this was I think tomorrow I'm
getting fisherman of the Year delivered
to your house
I don't even fish if you could call me
when it comes cuz I'm I want to see if I
won which I did there's so many people
where this could have gone to this is oh
oh people that are doing as much as I am
hello hosting the show every day have
you to set up the camera the lights
myself oh yeah here's how hard it is to
book the show ring ring ring hello
you wanna do Conan ring ring ring hello
big stir you want to do Conan whoa so
many phones so many people want to do
the show Spielberg what's that crews
what's that hello hello hello I wanted
to be a big unveiling on the air and
also I need you to drive that over to my
house oh my god I love it here in an
hour I'd love to show my wife oh oh oh
on the way if you could stop there's a
place that does great takeout
and they do it very safely it's called
Kai's and then bring those things to my
house ring the doorbell and then I'll
get it after you're gone that'd be great
yes employee of the month and my
favorite food this is so horrifying you
just can't handle that something nice
happen for me you're just bitter and
jealous that finally something went
Conan's way on the Conan show hey guess
what next month it might be you hold on
a second no I just found out it's me
again I win twice next month to stop
wait a minute grab a cup huh put some
liquor in it that's
at the new song everyone's singing it
wouldn't kill you to congratulate me
widget for as long as I live I will
never congratulate you for this I can
have the editors have you say
congratulations Conan using someone
else's voice and it'll look like it's
coming out of your lips
congratulations Conan Thank You Sona I
appreciate it